Liz truss has three hours to save her
Premiership we have quasi-quarting we
think he's just gone in the back
entrance of Downing Street for a
showdown meeting with Liz truss in which
he very much might end up losing his
position as Chancellor a U-turn was
agreed while quasi-quarting was in the
air done and dusted pretty much at the
time that ba jet touched down at
Heathrow what an hour and a half ago and
now quasiquating entering Downing Street
in order to discover his fate amid
claims that he is about to be sacked
sacked in a way that some of his MPS
worry will look like a scapegoating for
decisions that Liz trust made promises
she made during her leadership contest
we are expecting potentially within
hours Liz truss at a press conference to
announce that she is u-turning again on
her mini budget this time potentially
ditching her promise to freeze the
corporation tax rate allowing it to rise
allowing more cash to flow into the
treasury coffers in order to try and get
down the amount of money that Britain
has to borrow in future after an
enormous borrowing spree in the first
five and a half weeks of her entering
government that have spooked the market
put up interest rates and prompted a
political as well as an economic crisis
we could find out about the future of
the chancellor quasiquarting potentially
within hours we will also all be able to
judge in an early afternoon press
conference with Liz truss whether she
can save her own Premiership which right
now is on the line Liz truss is having
to fight for her political survival
because the ideas she has been in were
hers she thought of them she got a
Chancellor to do them she defended them
as recently as Wednesday in the House of
Commons her officials were issuing
statement as late as eight o'clock this
morning saying that she trusts the
chancellor has full confidence is
working in lockstep now she's going to
have to swallow not only one bad
decision bad because she's having to
u-turn on it but she's going to have to
somehow signal an entire change of
approach she might have to find a new
Chancellor that Chancellor could be
somebody completely different maybe a
Jeremy Hunt figure we don't yet know but
she will also have to promise that never
again will she create the turbulence and
the disruption that she very much made
the trademark of her Premiership she
signaled it during the campaign that she
was going to do it and very much we've
seen that turbulence come true despite
all the warnings uh from uh rival M Tori
MPS during the leadership campaign she's
going to prob got to promise and
Incredibly commit to never allowing that
situation to happen again
it's going to be incredibly challenging
at this press conference later today Liz
truss is going to have to announce the
scale of the u-turns from the mini
budget three weeks ago she's going to
have to convince the market that she can
now be trusted after weeks that have put
Britain's credibility on the line in a
way that hasn't happened in decades she
has got to convince her own MPS that
when she sacks this Chancellor and finds
a new one it is them that it's that
switch that stabilizes things rather
than her being the problem against a
backdrop where this man was not the only
problem viewed in the market uh uh and
amongst Tory MPS but actually it's the
Prime Minister herself her instincts her
decisions her insistence on doing things
differently that has been one of the
main drivers of the turbulence that
we've seen that's led us to this point
can Liz trust do all of those things uh
at two o'clock three o'clock this
afternoon and a very very important day
in the premiere ship of Liz trust we are
already talking about her battling for
survival when she hasn't even been in
office six weeks those were the gates of
Downing streets the press conference
take place on the right that's the front
door of Downing Street a hive of
activity uh this morning as officials
going in and out to try and prepare for
what's coming next it's quite clear to
me that the treasury in the end slightly
left floundering uh in the last couple
of days as number 10 took back economic
control of the big decisions in this
government and they set the pace
reversing things in the mini budget it
was advice to the Prime Minister direct
it was a um it was discussioned in
Downing Street not the treasury that
have led to the moment where we now
expect Corporation attacks uh the
corporation tax policy to be junked and
Liz truss uh uh in Downing Street which
you can see behind those gates to be
announcing that herself later today with
a big question about whether or not she
can do that credibly uh but what's her
plan to fix it and will her plan be good
enough to reassure the people in
Parliament which you can now see behind
you just beyond the war memorial can you
see them supporting her at this tricky
time in her Premiership so much
uncertainty the big political challenge
is whether or not voters will ever come
back and the market will ever uh regard
Britain as less risky with her in charge
voters in many many cases thinking not
just she made one bad decision but are
actually now genuinely uh questioning
whether or not uh genuinely questioning
whether or not she hasn't undermined the
Tories core reputation for economic
competence something just so much more
difficult to put behind a van there
leaving Downing Street uh it's a
Furniture van I'm not sure quasi quality
wants to see Furniture Vans going in and
out of Dentistry at this point uh dare I
say some might think it looks a little
bit like a removal van too early to say
uh it's a a fast and move moving
situation but what's certain is that
very very soon we're going to find out
about the future of quasi-quarting we
think from photographers uh passing on
information that he's got in the back
door of number 10. there he is there he
is I think that's the back of number 10
not a happy face from quasiquarting
there he is still as Chancellor but the
question on everybody's lips in
Whitehall is for how much longer as he
goes back to discuss the U-turn agreed
while he was out of the country and find
out whether Liz trust still wants him as
his Chancellor Liz truss and crazy
quieting very very close political
bedfellas the two of them have worked
together incredibly closely through the
leadership campaign he was working with
her even when Boris Johnson was prime
minister the two of them formed a little
cabal in the cabinet on things like
Northern Ireland policy brexit policy
and together they they fought for her to
become Prime Minister and now almost
without without us even hitting the six
week anniversary of this government it
looks as if he's getting out of that car
to go into Downing Street potentially to
lose his job maybe to another cabinet
role possibly to the back benches as it
turned out the turbulence between the
Prime Minister and the chancellor just
became too difficult there have been so
many disagreements just in their first
five weeks whether it's on whether or
not to scrap the top rate of tax uh Liz
trust publicly blaming quasiquarting on
telly for the decision to do that uh
policy in the first place uh when that
was scrapped in the middle
of a conservative party conference uh
whether it was policy on the bank of
England whether it's who uh which civil
servants should run the treasury there
is just a Litany of things that we know
about that I know about that we've
talked about on Sky News have been the
tensions between Liz truss and quesy
quieting now it appears coming to the
head over junking in large part the mini
budget the exact details of which we are
going to find out later today but we
believe it includes uh the decision not
to rise corporation tax uh corporation
tax will now rise we will find out very
soon whether the man you're looking at
going into Downing Street is going to be
in the job in a few hours time